Facebook may be facing its worst crisis
ever
it follows revelations that the personal
data of users was misused by a political
consulting firm and concerned the
problem could be widespread and the
company's response so far hasn't and
earned many thumbs up just yesterday
another tech giant Elon Musk
decided to join the delete Facebook
movement and deleted both the SpaceX and
Tesla Facebook accounts Jessi Hempel is
Wired magazine senior writer of the
business of Technology her article this
week is titled the irreversible damage
of Mark Zuckerberg silence Jessi welcome
I think there have been so many twists
and turns to this story just give us an
update right now where are we on this
well to start you have to understand
what Cambridge analytic it is right
Cambridge analytical was a company that
claimed to make a business out of
selling politicians and businesses the
ability to find you and change your mind
and last week a week in a day ago it
came out that it had used Facebook data
to do that in a way that violated users
trust and where we are right now well
finally we have heard from Facebook
finally the CEO and in fact that Sheryl
Sandberg and Mark Zuckerberg both have
spoken meanwhile Cambridge analytic is
in free fall
the CEO has left it I think they have no
CEO at the moment you have regulators
asking all times types of questions you
have government officials in the UK
investing Cambridge in investigating
Cambridge analytical and then back in
the u.s. you have users asking this
really important question which is
should I be spending so much time on
Facebook maybe I should delete it
and some people actually are pulling out
of Facebook and mention Elon Musk is the
probably the most high profile as Reena
mentioned your article is titled
irreversible damage of Mark Zuckerberg
silence which went on for days what is
the damage of that silence well first of
all you have to understand that silence
in light of what Facebook is you know
many companies can weather crises and
the CEO can step back but Facebook is a
different kind of company it's a company
that has built its reputation on the
reputation of its founder Mark
Zuckerberg is our central friend when
things go right mark talks to us
things the wrong mark talks to us five
days mark did not talk to us and the
people that matters to most right now
are going to be regulators who are
asking to hear more from Facebook about
how it's using our data you know we
talked about these regulators but you
know is Facebook really an American
company in the sense that they've got
servers all over the world they've
impacted Cambridge analytical has been
pointing to impacting elections in Kenya
and countries across the globe right
right so who's gonna really regulate
this when it's not just an American
thing or just a British thing right
you're asking exactly the right question
we don't know how to regulate a business
like this there is no previous model for
doing this I think one of the big
pressures that Facebook is going to face
over time is going to be a business
pressure because if you and I as users
decide that Facebook isn't the service
that we want it to be we will stop using
it and if we stop using it
advertisers won't be able to find us on
it and they will pull back now that's
not something that we have seen yet but
that is something that could really
change Facebook Facebook knew about the
misuse of data as far back as 2015 is
that correct that's right and I should
say Facebook did the things that
Facebook did back in 2015 to try to do
something about it it got in touch with
Cambridge analytic it said hey you've
missed you start data please destroy it
in Cambridge analytic as I understand
said okay we did now the problem is that
there was no Chuck to make sure they did
and even if there had been a check it's
pretty impossible to figure out once the
cat is out of the bag so to speak it's
pretty impossible to figure out what
happens to the data it's a fascinating
story so many twists and turns you have
to come still Jessie hempel thank you
for joining us thank you